anyways jake paul fight yeah i don't
know oh man what are we gonna do what
we're gonna do i [ __ ] was so pumped
for that what are we gonna do now play
beer pong
the narrative
is that tommy is ducking the fight
i know that's what i've heard
they are uh
that's i preface that with the narrative
because you know i don't watch enough
boxing to know
what the
issue is here you know jake is saying he
just needs to get a visa and tommy is
saying he can't
so who's ducking
go fight in the uk
i do
i will say i kind of
edge it out towards jake not kind of i
edged out towards jake
because if you do put on an event and
you have had people buy tickets already
you can't just [ __ ] like refunding 20
000 tickets that's a nightmare man no i
know i get it but isn't this the second
time this has happened now yeah what was
the first time uh tommy had an injury oh
it's supposed to be tommy fury
and that's why the second fight
yeah
so i mean
it's like full me one shame on me yeah
or shame on you fool me twice shame on
me right it fooled me we can't get
fooled again yeah well this guy got
dupes now twice by the tommy it's like i
think the greatest lol here would be if
haseem ramen
rahman i don't want to [ __ ] his name up
hands jake his first loss and it's just
like a boring decision yeah
and it's just like regular boxing
yeah well he he outpointed him
everyone's like why the [ __ ] did we come
to this yeah
so here we go do we have what rules
what what rules you sons of [ __ ]
oh my god
do it again do it again do it again what
rules you sons of [ __ ] [ __ ]
what rules
what rules you sons of [ __ ]
he sounds like that tick tock trend from
like a year ago or two years ago when
like girlfriends would use the wavy
voice talking about all right
chicken nuggets
[Music]
one more time one more time what rules
you sons of [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude he seems like he's a meat canyon
character
like the small eyes and the darkness
just slender body with this giant head
what the rules
this is
what rules your sons of [ __ ]
oh my god dude
what rules
this guy's a multi-millionaire off books
man
dude pizza rules yeah what rules what
rules you sons of [ __ ]
oh pizza
i just said pizza rules
oh
so it's crazy that that guy
was like literally on life support for
[ __ ] benzos
and now he's back here yeah yeah if i
had a if i had a kiss with death like
that
coming back to be bitching about twitter
you didn't learn your lesson dude yeah
you did not learn your lesson yeah you
almost went out like for real yeah
what do you do with your second chance
get pissed about twitter get pissed
about twitter yeah you can't be mad
online anymore come on man yeah or is it
kind of like respectable to like
be like
what rules you sons of [ __ ]
you know so he's flatlined and then
yeah yeah jack i'm coming every time
i'm not done what i need to
achieve online
look at the way they villainize you on
it's a joke bro he you want just had two
new kids you see his executive yeah he's
he has nine children that is not boating
well for the uh he didn't get massages
on the airplane yeah argument
oh yeah yeah why is he [ __ ] porking
his employees dude yeah
yeah amanda's trying to spread the seed
clearly
yeah
and he keeps joe it's such a creepy joke
what does he do he keeps joking about it
on twitter like
uh the fertility rates going on the
fertility rate's going down i'm doing my
best
to save the human race though it's like
ugh i don't want to [ __ ]
think
thinking about him like piping out
whoever he can just like pump out more
kids just so we can ignore them
yeah it's just like the creepiest
weirdest thought
yeah what i don't get is um
if you're i don't know if you're an elon
fan
how do you look at all this and still go
no this guy is like
he's definitely
he's definitely stable yeah and like
normal yeah and definitely uh like a
leader of industry
i don't know i hope you have big
families and congrats to those who
already do i mean i don't know maybe
maybe he does like see his own kids but
he's always doing other things he's
running like nine of the biggest
companies in the world
he definitely does not spend time with
his kids
we can say that with confidence right we
have our
just our fun little network here
and i still have days where i'm like i
have a dog
[Laughter]
so
there's no [ __ ] way seeing his kids
zero away
like people have kids
and like they
they do a symbolic death in like their
dungeons and dragons group you know
you you run spacex you already don't see
your kids yeah you know spacex plus
these other things plus you have nine of
them you don't see your kids man
yeah so isn't that kind of messed up
yeah dude
yeah
it is
like just to know that that's that's
what your role in their life is gonna be
yeah it's the sort of absent father that
they that's the most achieved man like
in the world
well apparently he like idolizes his
grandfather and that's kind of it seems
like the relationship he had like with
his grandfather and
arguably
distant yeah or like non-existent
just
he's just working on creating um a myth
about him and then he can just die and
then his kids can reference the myth
yeah
and uh or the myth that the public
references and all those kids are like
yeah i don't really [ __ ] know that
dude
i just watch him tweet all the time yeah
that's a grim feeling yeah you're a musk
child and it's like your eighth birthday
your dad couldn't make it because uh
but he tweeted about you yeah
look at he tweeted happy birthday to my
eighth child
he didn't say your name he just said
eighth child
i just wanted a train set
yeah yeah oh he tweeted a picture of a
train set
look at that
yeah man
sons of [ __ ] you sons of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
there's nothing we're going to say
that's going to beat that i know
objectively the funniest i know
i could we could say that for next 30
minutes it'd be a good episode yeah i
agree
you don't have to try i agree you know
totally
like there's someone laughing in their
car right now that's like dudes just
stop it's not funny you sons of [ __ ]
okay like enough
what rules
what rules
what's a funny situation that you could
be in where you could say that like
where you're breaking the rules but you
know it's like a stupid rule to begin
with i feel like some goofy like board
game night with family okay that's
that's a good one yeah yep then you
cheat a little bit yeah oh getting
pulled over by the police yeah okay yep
just doing a crime in general okay
what rules
sons of [ __ ]
can't kill those cats all right
all right all right if you get a parking
ticket in real time you catch the guy
the silence what's the meter that's
something that's the rules
rules
what rules you sons of [ __ ]